fbi i've spoken with the governor
and i'll be speaking with the mayor on
the
on the aircraft we're working very
closely with the state and local law
enforcement officials and they're going
to keep me updated as they learn more
you're going to ask me to speculate
understandably you'd ask me expected
about
what happened why it happened and i'm
not going to do that now because we
don't have all the information
not until i have all the facts but i do
know this
as president i'm going to use all the
resources of my disposal
to keep the american people safe as i
said
at this moment a great deal remains
unknown
but three things are certain first
10 lives have been lost and more
families have been shattered by gun
violence in the state of colorado
and jill and i are devastated
and the feeling i just
can't imagine how the families are
feeling the victims
whose futures were stolen from them from
their families from their loved ones
who now have to struggle to go on and
try to make sense of what's happened
less than a week after the horrific
murders of eight people
and the assault on the aapi community in
georgia
while the flag was still flying half
staff
for the tragedy and other american
cities been scarred by gun violence
and resulting trauma and the state that
i even hate to say it because
we're saying it so often my heart goes
out
our hearts go out for the survivors
the who had to uh had to flee for their
lives
and who hid terrified unsure if they
would ever
see their families again their friends
again
the consequences of all this are deeper
than i
suspect we know by that i mean the
mental consequences
the feeling of anyway just
through too many of these the second
point i want to make is my
deepest thanks to the heroic police and
other first responders who acted so
quickly to address the situation
and keep the members of our community
safe
the state the obviously the obvious i
commend the exceptional bravery
of officer eric talley i send my deepest
condolence to his family
his close close family and seven
children
you know when he pinned on that badge
yesterday morning
he didn't know what the day would bring
i want everybody to think about this
every time an officer walks out of his
or her home and pins that badge on
the family member that they just said
goodbye to
wonders whether they'll subconsciously
will they get that call
a call that his wife got he thought he'd
be coming home to his family and his
seven children
when the moment the act came officer
tully
did not hesitate in his duty
making the ultimate sacrifice in his
effort to save lives
that's a definition of an american hero
and thirdly i want to be very clear
this is the one thing i do know enough
to say on in terms of what's happened
there
while we're still waiting for more
information regarding the shooter his
motive
the weapons he used the guns the
magazines the weapons the modifications
that apparently have taken place
to those weapons that are involved here
i don't need to wait another minute let
alone an hour
to take common sense steps i will save
the lives
in the future and to urge my colleagues
in the house and senate to act
we can ban assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines
in this country once again i got that
done when i was a senator
it passed it was law for the longest
time
and it brought down these mass killings
we should do it again
we can close the loopholes in our
background check system
including the charleston loophole that's
one of the best tools we have right now
to prevent gun violence the senate
should immediately pass
let me say it again the united states
senate
i hope some are listening should
immediately pass the two house pass
bills that close loopholes
in the background check system these are
bills
that receive votes of both republicans
and democrats in the house
this is not it should not be a partisan
issue
this is an american issue it will save
lives
american lives we have to act
we should also ban assault weapons in
the process
i'll have much more to say as we learn
more but i wanted to be clear
those poor folks who died left behind
families
leaves a big hole in their hearts
and and we can save lives
increasing the background checks like
they're supposed to occur
and eliminating assault weapons and the
size of magazines i don't know all the
detail yet on that
but i'll be talking to you more later
today or the next couple days
about what else we know may god bless
you all
and those families who are mourning
today because of gun violence in
colorado and georgia
all across the country we have to act
so there's not more of you there's fewer
of you as time goes on
thank you so much will you introduce new
gun legislation mr president